night
let this be a reminder to us all that
money has absolutely touched the naked
parts of someone else
naked hands yes sure but also naked
butts and naked toes and naked crabs
so please for the love of spongebob
never put money in your mouth
wash your hands clean the floors change
your underwear
but in reverse order right if he finds
one health violation
he'll close us down for good that's not
how health inspections work
we've got to do everything in our power
to make sure he passes
the krusty krab i've passed a krusty
grab before and let me tell you it's not
something to brag about it's actually
very very painful
you really haven't got any brains at all
have you son probably not he's a
sponge i just need to try a plain krabby
patty and my inspection will be finished
yup because why would a health inspector
need to check the cleanliness of the
restaurant by looking at the kitchen
no no the health inspector needs to eat
the food to taste if the kitchen is
nasty
cartoon pantaloon we interrupt this can
can for a special news bulletin
self-aware news position he is the
imposter
we've been duped and to confirm your
suspicions you'll call the health
department a fact check in order to
avoid possibly doing something stupid
like
murdering someone right oh hold on i've
got a gyro toenail clippings in my
office
i suppose we should focus on the
positive here and be thankful that there
aren't toenail clippings strewn all over
the floor
however i am very concerned as to why mr
k would be collecting toenail clippings
and from whom
considering he has no toes and neither
does anyone under the sea
how is he getting toenail clippings
toilet paper that can resist dissolving
underwater is
not something that anyone should want to
scrape along their undercarriage
hello delicious earlier the health
inspector said i just need to try a
plain krabby patty and this one is
clearly not
plain so why is he even attempting to
take a bite human teeth
tongue and uvula in a fish this tiny fly
managed to lodge itself in the throat of
a fish that just moments ago
easily swallowed this food chalk none of
the motions of the flailing arms and
legs propel this fish around the space
that is
filled with water that patty killed him
no that patty is clearly a delicious
patty with fresh ingredients if you're
gonna go through all the trouble of
animating this monstrosity
you may as well continue to disgust us
by having the actual nasty patty on the
floor rather than these fresh
ingredients
i think you're getting yourself confused
with mop bob string pants with you
they'd simply wipe off the counter and
potentially make creative use of your
many holes
how is the body laying down in this
position when in the previous scene the
head was upright i'll overlook that it's
raining underwater but i won't overlook
that it's raining underwater and krusty
and spongebob are still as dry as they
were before the rain fell
the sign is now on the right never mind
it's where it should be again that was
almost only one sin the health inspector
pulled up earlier and has been here all
day well except for when he was being
buried alive but my question is where is
his car he pulled up and parked in the
middle of the street earlier did someone
steal it
move it dude where's his car also
honestly i'm glad i saw that because i
forgot to send parking in the street
that is rude
hey there's no ice mr k just pulled a
drink from beneath the counter without
going to get a fresh soda and you're
concerned about ice
what's happening to me in my diet the
krusty krab
is the most perfect place in the
universe this could very well be the
stupidest person on the face of the
earth
you looney loofah he is the imposter
[Music]
we've been duped dealt bamboozled we've
been smuggled
that's not even a word we are laughing
put him down now he's a mad dog i'm
sorry what's a mad dog
put that muddy shovel in the trunk and
we'll give you a ride back hope you have
a big trunk
because i'm putting my bike in it